uh it looks really nice and what a great
thing they're doing for veterans and
their families today
gorgeous blue skies i mean we had clouds
uh just not even half an hour ago and
they have
really started thinning out and moving
on so we have got a nice veterans day
ahead of us it's chilly out there as
bianca said and you can tell
it's cold we've got 36 at mountain's
edge 39 on the strip
centennial hills at 39 38 at sunrise
mountain seven hills
you're in the mid-30s so we're pretty
close to where we were yesterday
we only warmed up to 57 yesterday i
think we're going to add a few more
degrees onto that
by the afternoon valley in the 20s again
upper 20s red rock at 30. again you need
a reservation
but no entrance fee today for veterans
day that's awesome 43 in
laflin 36 in boulder city the veterans
memorial cemetery out there i bet we'll
have
quite a few more folks visiting although
the clouds are thinning out
we're going to stay dry more clouds
tonight though with the system might
bring some showers to the mountains
and ada has turned back into a hurricane
spinning
back over florida again with lots of
rain no rain for us
just sunshine 61 degrees we'll get more
clouds tonight and tomorrow could bring
a slight chance
of some showers to the mountains for
thursday and then we're on to a
sunny warmer weekend check out those 70s
starting sunday even mid 70s
by tuesday